islam doesn't say that because we told
you allah
said do not be the secluded place the
third person shaytan therefore you rape
and justify that or attempting to rip
away
no it is the place where anybody you
wronged you will have to give them their
rights
one way like what does that mean but
sometimes we watch all videos of
ourselves and cringe what the bro what
the what the rash
like what what what the hell was i doing
brothers and sisters
give people chances
from a juvenile where my clothes had
holes in love
and my afro was picky to the nighties
moschino and versace no laces in iraqis
new millennium
hope you guys are willing inshallah i
start one who plays allah the most
merciful the most trust or praise his
glory and gratitude belong to him
recent controversy in scandal has arisen
once again
um this time regarding brother the
double kim
and the allegations are that he
attempted to rape
a muslim sister now before we delve into
that
brothers and sisters we need to
understand something yeah um
that this is something regarding another
person
violating the rights of another person
so the sharia has come down to protect
that
yeah protect individuals and community
as a whole so i'm not here
with my opinion you know a lot of people
have been jumping on board people come
to me and say brother i'll do a video
etc
like it's a joke you know um and there
was those who genuinely wanted
to do a video for other like reasons to
you know uh which we're going to come to
yeah
so with these things mom and sisters
nobody cares about your opinion
my opinion we are nobody yeah these are
matters that are
crimes and in islam they're crimes and
islam has come to protect the rights
of individuals yeah sometimes in certain
situations the females rights are
greater than a man's
yeah and certain situations a man's
rights is greater than a woman
and certain situation both of their
rights are as equal so brothers and
sisters when we're touching this will
come in from an islamic angle
i'm not coming from my angle my opinion
no one cares about my opinion in this
matter i'm not i made any more meaning
for people to run to me
and look for solutions but in this
specific match i'm going to tell you
guys why i'm doing this video because i
didn't want anything to do with it
but i'm going to tell you guys why i'm
doing it now the first thing
my impression was to stay silent
be silent why because brothers and
sisters when these things happen
you'll have two kinds of groups yeah one
group attacking
the other yeah if there's two peop one
person is wrong the other
they come to his defense or her defense
and start attacking another one comes to
the rescue
you shouldn't do none of that you should
be silent and wait
wait and see what's going on because a
lot of people are going to be in regret
they're going to
as things unfold you're going to regret
certain things and that's why they just
took a step back and waited not that i
was going to do a video i just wanted to
analyze and see what's actually going on
for myself so
now it's very important for us to stay
silent brothers and sisters yeah a lot
of scholars
scholars have said that they have never
they have regretted many times speaking
but they have never regretted being
silent yeah be insane be quiet sometimes
analyze it
and the prophet salallahu sallam said
that whoever guarantees what's between
his
his uh jaws yeah jaw bones and what is
between these two legs
i will guarantee paradise for him
meaning those who protect their chastity
from zinna
what's between your legs your private
parts and whoever protects what's
between their jaws and the tongue
yeah a lot of people end up in the fire
because of their tongue slandering
backbiting you name it yeah and it leads
to the fire so the process and i'm
saying
quiet yeah if you've got nothing good to
say stay silent
so brother and sister that is the first
thing of action that we need to do
that's the first thing that i want to
tell you guys
i'm going to go for seven points here
that's the first thing when these
scandals come out from the sisters
whatever it may be
be silent you will not regret being
silent
okay until things have unfolded now
from what i know brothers and sisters
that a brother
would kim a video was a video emerged
of him um at the bottom of the stairs
putting his trousers on and then you've
got a cyst
excuse me a sister who's distraught
who's crying
yeah and she's accusing him of allegedly
raping her now when it comes to islam
visual content can be manipulated yeah
and we know that with the deep
the deep fake or something like that
yeah it can be manipulated
yeah so when it comes to instance like
obviously one has to be careful man
because in today's time
within some weird times all kinds of
stuff happened however brother that
kim came out and verified that so it
reminds us of the story of the man who
came to the prophet salallahu and also a
woman came once as well
and he said i committed zinna the
prophet moved away from him
and he said i committed zinna the
prophet moved away from him
and he said it the third time the
process hasn't moved away from him why
because he knows how severe the
punishment is going to be now in this
very instance
zinna actually means one penetrating
the vagina as simple as that that is
actual penetration happening
in this very instance that didn't happen
yeah but the point that i'm trying to
say is that
brother dole came out himself and said
yes
this happened so now
the thing is this problem sisters yeah
there's a big misconception yeah there's
a big big big
uh uh misconception yeah that
misconception
is that for example allah says islam is
all about prevention then cure okay
prevent it from the roots rather than oh
let's look for a cure yeah so
allah subhana wa says stay away from
zina
yeah do not be in a secluded place now
listen to me carefully before people
start jumping to conclusions
oh my gosh are you victim blaming listen
to me
the misconception is this just because
allah's mission says stay away from
sinner
don't indulge with the opposite gender
do not be in a secluded place
not being in a secluded place where
allah allegedly is to avoid zinna
this doesn't mean that if a man and a
woman is in a secluded place and the man
attempts to rape her
or i don't know if this is even possible
a woman tries to rape him
i'm so sorry i'm not trying to be sexist
but i highly doubt that happens yeah
i don't know anyways i don't want to get
into that yeah it doesn't justify
you can't come and say oh you guys were
in a secluded place
you deserved it girl that's nonsense
islam doesn't say that because we told
you allah
said do not be secluded please the third
person in shaytan therefore you rape and
justify that or attempting to rip away
no it is haram number one you are in a
haram
you're committing haram because you're a
secluded place yeah in the context it
can lead to haram
yeah you should not be and now on top of
that you are violating the right of
another person
there is no excuse so when allah tells
the believing
woman to cover herself up it's not
allah doesn't say cover up because men
can't control themselves
the men should be low in their gaze from
the get-go it's got enough to do that so
this big misconception
can be thrown out the window it's
pathetic and it's silly
yeah and what really annoyed me further
which is actually point
four but i'll come straight to it now is
that certain people who are a fan
of brother dawood kim is attacking
this sister and that is pathetic it's
absolutely
i'm so sorry it's stupid yes i'm going
to call it stupid yeah
and i've got this big word as
preposterous yeah i'm sure that's the
word that exists like that yeah
what the hell is wrong with you guys how
could you blame
somebody who like was attempted to get
raped
yeah you can't it's it's absolutely
wrong brother dawud kim in his video
pointed that out as well is please for
god's sake
this is not islam so that's why i'm
saying this video is not about your
opinion or my opinion
this is about islam you cannot attack a
sister
a female oh you should have not been
there that's besides the point
she may have committed a haram in the
context of letting him in
but she is not to blame to be raped or
attempted to be raped
yeah that is wrong so let's make that
very categorically clear
islam doesn't say you are to blame
because
oh you shouldn't i'm so sorry yeah no
it does it doesn't okay
and now one thing that we need to
highlight is the following
yeah just to be just this was before
islam
now saying this was before islam does
not
mean that we're saying what was done was
right
what was saying is that the lifestyle he
lived and he said on his reverse story
that it was chaos yeah suicidal or if
i'm
taking you know drinking etc
okay now the fingers brothers and
sisters we need to understand
that the life and i come from that
lifestyle in the context of clubbing and
girls and all that nonsense yeah
and it's a disgusting life it's such a
miserable life
yeah it's such a miserable life brothers
and sisters that will not wish on
anybody
yeah and that's why people come to islam
because
when they come to islam rivers are more
stern why because they acknowledge
the filth they came from and that's why
alcohol is the mother of
all evils alcohol is the mother of us
once again i repeat
i'm not saying that
um the the the like the trying to move
away the blame no
yeah even though he says he doesn't
remember anything alcohol is the mother
of all evils yeah that's what allah
told us to abstain from it so brother
and sister yeah so we need to understand
that
now one thing we need to clarify now i
know a lot of people say you know when
people come to islam
well all your sins are forgiven you're
gone whoa brand new amazing good
one thing when it comes to repentance
brothers and sisters when one repents
or one has come to islam there's three
conditions individuals
for the one who has wronged himself yeah
no sorry for the one
who has wronged himself yeah and wronged
allah
is that you stop the sin you make sure
you don't go back to it so you say oh
allah i'm gonna
not go back to inshallah i'm gonna try
yeah and
you hate the sin this is a condition for
one
violating him own self yeah violating to
him himself
now there's a fourth condition for the
one
who violates someone else's rights
we need to talk about this not beloved
i've watched a lot of videos reacted not
many people touched upon this i touch
upon it yeah
the fourth condition is that you need to
ask forgiveness from the very
person this is very important that you
ask forgiveness from the person because
you violated their right allah can
forgive you now the image i'm going to
have in front of your brother and
sisters
here shows that in islam our worldview
what happens from
us coming to this world to dying to
judgment day to be in judge
to the expected there's a specific place
brothers and sisters
in on the screen if you can see on the
screen bro and sisters is a place
called the the arch yeah i don't want to
say something term to it yeah
this place is just those who crossed the
cerat
the hellfire yeah over there fire and
this
is the place where anybody you wronged
you will have to give them their rights
one way or another yeah there's
different narrations etc
that you know if you have good deeds you
know you would give it to that person if
you have no good deeds left
then they will you will have to carry
their sins etc etc yeah so this is
something that is very severe
very severe that it's one of the
conditions of repentance not only that
if like if those people who you have
wronged on the under the judgment before
you enter heaven oh you're going to be
stopped
you're from this person brother good
easy i know you did a lot of good deeds
but this person allah takes it seriously
when you violate the right of others
allah is just so brothers and sisters so
he needs to ask for forgiveness if you
have taken money from someone you have
to return that money you owe someone
money
you have to give that money back and and
the list continues yes so let's make
that very very clear okay
now as far as i know what dawood brother
that would said is that
before that they pressed charges right
they saw
okay and the charges were dropped
because she dropped charges if i look i
don't know the story yeah
that they met and he apologized
he said he was drunk or whatever
happened and he apologized
now if he apologized and if from what i
know she accepted it
the case is closed when i'm in the case
of clause i'm saying
she's apologized she if she is accepted
because from what i know he said he is
and there was a document paper et cetera
the case is closed jani the case is
closed in the context of
he made a mistake the case is cause this
was about yeah like before
apparently before islam as far as i know
the case is close she's forgiven
yeah and may allah reward the sister for
forgiving him yeah
okay so the case is closed okay so
from what i know the case should be
closed now the one thing that i want to
advise brother though then i spoke to
him in private and i'm still speaking in
private
you know because i didn't think one
other concern that we had was
that the rights of the sister and now
the rights of himself
because he looks like he's in a bad
place and we can't abandon him yeah
now brother and sister we need to
understand something here every single
one of us are sinners man seriously
seriously man every one of us are
sinners okay
sometimes my past haunts me as well yeah
it haunts me as well
there's people that have wronged yeah
there's people have wronged as well yeah
and i have to like i haven't done
nothing crazy but the thing is there's
people that are frogged
i've hurt and i think to myself what the
hell was i thinking
it was ja hilly i was ignorant yeah
now if he's repented genuinely
brother would you should have not
exposed your sins further
yeah i've told you this as well but you
should not go into detail because you
did say that
you did drink alcohol being as a muslim
etc
and i know look when i came to islam i
had a few bad tricks man
it was hard to get rid of them
eventually i did allah helped me by
getting involved in the dow
alhamdulillah
but brother dawud you should not mention
your sins that is between you and your
lord
yeah and like i said bro and sisters
it's by allah's mercy
that allah hides our sins or will be
finished yet so that wasn't really wise
i know he was not in the right place but
you should not mention and that's why i
love this theme of abu bakr allah he
said
that when people praised him he said may
allah forgive me for what you do not
know about me
and may allah make me better than what
you think of me because you've got high
view of me may allah make me better
and may allah forgive me because it's by
his mercy
that you don't know stuff about me yeah
so i would just advise him that don't do
that inshallah
and one thing i want to mention is that
you know yes you drunk alcohol there was
a companion of the prophet salallahu
sallam
he used to drink alcohol drink alco alco
yeah and uh
and they used to blush him yeah there
was punishment for lush
said that the last should be 80. yeah if
i'm saying 80 the same as slander
yeah why because he believed a drunk
person is more prone to slandering
people
so he said the lush is his understanding
should be 80 lashes yeah they would lash
him why because it was it was a major
sin yeah
but one day some companies he would keep
doing the same thing and when the
companies came and said may allah curse
you
the process of someone said don't say
that don't say that
indeed he loves allah and his messenger
brothers and sister this is the process
of celebrating
you see in a man who's finally if there
was today if you have the super salafi
subhanallah
the court members they would finish you
off yeah you're done
yeah and
affirming that he loves allah and his
messenger even though he's committing a
sin drinking alcohol etc yeah
we ask allah to forgive your prophet and
to work
in yourself inshallah maybe it wasn't a
good idea to jump on youtube straight
away um
and i would say take some time out yeah
take some time out
self-reflection so it might be good but
take some time out
rectify one intention this is something
that i suffer on a daily basis
rectify one's intentions do that
inshallah but one thing i want to say to
you about
what i've said to you in private as well
and i'm going to tell everybody here
if we're going to disregard people and
totally if this sister who's been a
victim
is asking for dawood to totally be
obliterated like finnish khalastan this
is wrong
i'm so sorry if he's changed his ways to
the better
the sister should say you know what yes
what he did was wrong to me
yeah and rightly so but
to say to him that he can't be a changed
man and change his ways for the better
i'm so sorry this is wrong
this is absolutely wrong if that's the
case then let's talk take away all the
sahaba the companions
used to bury his daughter alive he used
to cry he used to cry
how did he do this brothers and sisters
this is what jahilia is this is what
living in ignorance is brothers and
sisters we do not know what we're
thinking
there's certain things i look back and
i'm like what the [ __ ] was i thinking
like i'm looking about like
like what does that mean but sometimes
we watch old videos of ourselves and
we're crying what the bro what the what
the rash
like what what what the hell was i doing
brothers and sisters give people chances
yeah
i know in korea i was watching a video
that some people say that in korea it's
very strict people don't give people
chances well sorry what allah does
yeah so i i give you a chance and
brother kim i highly recommend you to
put your videos back
up your videos what you did i don't want
you to shaytan to work on you and
no and i believe it's unfair for him to
take all his videos down
because of the pressure it's unfair he's
doing good works
yes he should i'm seeing he should keep
those up and take time out reflect
and come back yeah come back because if
you've changed yourself if you sincerely
repent you can't
question your intentions if you have
you've learned from your mistakes
you've apologized to the sister the
sisters accepted move on
inshallah yeah and we ask the sister to
forgive him inshallah which we believe
he has
and the hope you guys have benefited
from this i'm going to leave you at that
inshaallah
and brahman sisters brother dawood um
like i said we are here for you in
in the context of if you feel depressed
or whatever and we know how it is
and brahman's sisters inshallah we ask
you to make dua for all of us
and we ask allah to protect us wallahi
it's by his mercy
it's by his mercy promises and if
there's brothers watching this uh it's
off topic as well a bit
uh he brothers in the scene inshaallah
money
fame and woman yeah these are the
weaknesses of men
be very careful be very careful if you
are coming to do youtube videos
to gain these allah will humiliate you
allah will immediate you so yeah
that's it guys till next time inshallah
alaikum
hope you warahmatullahi have benefited
from this five minutes anything else
forgive me if i've said anything wrong
it's for myself anything good for me is
messenger
till next time
by the way guys how's my how's me with
the classes
do comment in the comment section bye